[Música]
hola buenas tardes soy hincha de
ferrocarril oeste
no era un chiste verdad
este es un club que es muy tradicional
para la clase media porteña para los que
no nos conocen y ferro es un club que
hace casi 20 años que estamos en la
segunda categoría del fútbol argentino
nuestro clásico rival es google star
field un club que durante los mismos
años que nosotros perdimos todos ellos
ganaron todo a hueles le dicen el fortín
y cerca del estadio de fútbol de este
club hay una pizzería que lleva el mismo
nombre
la pizza del fortín se las recomiendo la
verdad tienen la concesión y ximo
exacto tiene la masa muy gruesa la
mozzarella es casi como la masa chorrea
aceite por dos lados le tienen que poner
18 servilletas para no mancharse las
manos pero la pista del fortín se come
ahí o paramos en el mostrador o sentados
en la mesa no da que se la lleven a su
casa esa pista fría se convierte en algo
que es verdaderamente impasable
a nueve cuadras de la pizzería del
fortín está la cárcel de villa devoto el
único penal de máxima seguridad que
sobrevive en la capital de todos los
argentinos
efectivamente como decía el presentador
hace casi 30 años esa cárcel me atrapó
apellido eso fue lo primero que escuché
de un guardia penitenciario yo esperaba
buen día
pero no dice un buen día en la cárcel
con el tiempo entendí que un buen día es
claramente otra cosa que lo que pasa en
ese lugar
a la cárcel van aquellas personas que
son condenadas o son acusadas por haber
cometido un delito un delito es un
conflicto un conflicto grave de los más
graves que prevé en nuestro ordenamiento
jurídico
algunos de los que están acá cometió
algún delito alguna vez un delito va
desde lesiones desde haberse quedado con
algo que no es de uno el haber tenido
estupefacientes prohibidos alguna vez
levante la mano el que no cometió un
delito alguna vez
uno dos tres cuatro algunos mienten
7 lo cierto es que muchísimas personas
cometen un delito yo llamo la teoría del
embudo a las consecuencias o al
recorrido que lleva una persona a ir a
la prisión saben lo que es un embudo de
verdad esa cosa circular que después va
afinando se hasta pasar por un tubito
bueno la parte superior del embudo es
donde están estamos todos los que alguna
vez cometimos alguna conducta que el
código penal llama delito si después ese
embudo va afinando se es el sistema de
pesos y contrapesos el que tiene un buen
abogado el que no se puede probar el que
bueno estas cosas que pasan en nuestra
sociedad a veces van pasando por esos
distintos filtros y solamente los más
delgados pasan por el tubito del final
que tiene como destino la sanción más
grave que podemos prever para aquellos
que violentan el ordenamiento jurídico
la cárcel o sea que en la cárcel
todos los que cometen un delito ni
siquiera están los que cometen los
delitos más graves pero están los que
están y son los que son quiero hacer una
aclaración no se trata de justificar el
delito yo no hago eso no el delito en
general es una opción pero si hay que
entender porque si no entendemos de qué
hablamos cuando hablamos de prisión
entonces difícilmente podamos intervenir
para modificar una realidad que
verdaderamente nos tiene que preocupar a
todos
en la cárcel lo que nosotros llamamos
derecho se transforma en privilegio
visitas contacto con la familia la salud
la educación el tema de hoy dormir
tranquilo todo eso está normado por un
conjunto de premios y castigos que
tienen como regulación a la violencia
como forma eficaz de decidir quién tiene
razón
sin perjuicio de que esto es lo que pasa
en nuestras prisiones argentinas y que
la gente que está en ese lugar cumple
con la sanción que la ley establece lo
cierto es que la cárcel nos daña a todos
daña a las personas que se encuentran en
ese lugar y salen peor de lo que entran
a menudo las noticias nos asustan con
razón cuando nos enteramos de horrendos
crímenes producidos por personas que
alguna vez estuvieron en la cárcel daña
también a los trabajadores
penitenciarios que no tienen estímulos
para realizar sus tareas de acuerdo a lo
que la norma prevé a la norma que rige
la vida en las cárceles ya las normas
que rigen los derechos de un trabajador
y también daña al conjunto de la
sociedad porque una de cada dos personas
que pasan por las cárceles argentinas
van a volver a estar y probablemente
vuelvan a estar por haber cometido algo
mucho más grave que lo que los llevo en
el otro momento
del lugar de donde vienen nuestra
sociedad tiene cierta dosis de
hipocresía por cierto con todo esto
verdad nos preocupa el delito claro como
no nos va a preocupar en una sociedad
como la nuestra tenemos miedo tenemos
mucho miedo porque sabemos lo que nos
pasa y cuando tomamos conocimiento de
algún hecho de estos aberrantes
delictivos queremos que la justicia
llegue que llegue rápido que se imponga
y que castigue al responsable con esta
pena con la privación de la libertad la
más grave que le podemos aplicar a
alguien después cuando recuperan su
libertad nos volvemos a preocupar porque
sabemos que en las cárceles no se
aprende nada bueno y sabemos también
como dije antes que salen peor de lo que
entran entonces queremos que nos salgan
y que si salen que vuelvan a estar muy
rápido en la prisión pero la hipocresía
está dada porque no nos preocupa ese
mientras tanto lamentablemente las
herramientas con las que debiéramos
trabajar en contextos de encierro
adolecen estos privilegios regulados por
se convierten en excepción para poder
alcanzar y son las herramientas que
debiéramos utilizar en contextos de
encierro para motivar a esas personas
que están en esos lugares a que cuando
recuperen su libertad no produzcan
conflictos para ellos ni para con
terceros que estamos esperando que de
ahí salgan de otra manera
en este lugar sorprende que todavía
sorprenda que la regla sea la
reincidencia yo a veces me cuestiono si
la cárcel funciona mal no como puede ser
que todavía creamos que algo que sabemos
que produce daño
tenga como resultado producir daño lo
extraño sería que no quieran volver a
cometer delitos lo extraño es de la
prisión sería que la gente salga mejor
de lo que entra a veces creo que la
cárcel funciona bien busca producir daño
y lo logra con eficacia condiciona
falsas identidades obliga en muchísimos
casos a vivir de la violencia y del
delito en esos lugares y por si esto
fuera poco convierte al estado en
delincuente porque no sé si ustedes
saben que en las cárceles argentinas el
estado tolera y hace lo mismo que en el
medio libre reprocha
en las cárceles argentinas se roba en
las cárceles argentinas se vende droga
en las cárceles argentinas se viola en
las cárceles argentinas se mata todo
ante la vista de agentes estatales que
financiamos todos y que tendrían que
hacer lo contrario y que en muchísimas
ocasiones no sólo que no lo impiden sino
que también son los factores principales
de esta tragedia
yo les quiero contar una historia en el
mismo lugar de siempre pero gente que
intento hacer algo distinto basado en
una herramienta poderosísima que es la
educación
era el año 1985 la primavera democrática
para los que tuvimos el lujo de vivirla
sabemos que todos los sueños que
soñábamos creíamos que los podíamos
hacer realidad por el simple y solo
hecho de volver a vivir en democracia
fue así como unas madres de tres chicos
de tres jóvenes que estaban alojados en
ese penal en el de villa devoto las
mamás no siempre las mamás
incondicionales siempre no qué cosa lo
de las madres da para otra charla td
pero fueron tres mamás las que se
acercaron a la universidad de buenos
aires y le plantearon a la entonces
secretaria académica que sus hijos eran
jóvenes que habían estudiado en el medio
libre pero que ahora estaban en prisión
y que sabían que iban a perder muchas
cosas sus hijos la libertad no ya no es
poco perder la libertad por cierto pero
en la cárcel se pierde mucho más pero no
querían que pierdan la posibilidad de
continuar sus estudios universitarios
entonces
pidieron a esta funcionaria marta la
ferrière merece ser nombrada
si existía alguna posibilidad de
acercarles materiales de estudio a sus
hijos y que llegado el caso cuando
llegue la fecha de los exámenes y lo
podían llevar a la universidad para
rendir la materia recuerden que
estábamos en 1985 y que los sueños se
hacían a mano y sin pedir permiso a esta
funcionaria se le ocurrió algo distinto
también así como a estos chicos se le
ocurrió estudiar en ese lugar a esta
funcionaria se le ocurrió que més de que
vayan a estudiar a la universidad que la
universidad vaya a dar clases a la
prisión
se conversó con el servicio
penitenciario una institución difícil si
las hay vertical dura militarizada y
asia y fue la universidad una
institución horizontal democrática en
donde todos valemos uno y se llegó a un
acuerdo y el servicio penitenciario
le cedió un espacio para poder dar
clases en el penal de villa devoto el
espacio estaba destruido había se había
producido un motín años atrás era un
pabellón que había alojado jóvenes
adultos que tienen entre 18 y 21 años se
les llama jóvenes adultos jóvenes pides
ese motín había destruido por completo
el pabellón y solamente quedaban
escombros pero en donde algunos vieron
escombros otros soñaron una universidad
así fue con la donación de muchos con el
trabajo de los estudiantes privados de
libertad con la colaboración de algunos
agentes penitenciarios también las
celdas fueron reemplazadas por aulas las
paredes cáscaras fueron reemplazadas por
pizarrones las camas sin colchón y sin
frazadas
fueron reemplazados por pupitres y los
presos fueron reemplazados por alumnos
desde entonces la universidad de buenos
aires dicta algunas de las carreras
ofrecidas en contextos de encierro con
la misma metodología del afuera formamos
profesionales en el adentro hoy damos
las carreras de abogacía todas las de
ciencias económicas filosofía y letras
psicología sociología hacemos cursos de
extensión universitaria hacemos cursos
extracurriculares algunos aprenden a
leer y escribir en nuestras aulas con el
tiempo también nos fuimos ampliando ya
no estamos solamente en la cárcel de
villa devoto
hoy estamos en los penales de hombres
en la zona de ezeiza tan conocida hoy
también estamos en los penales para
adultos y para jóvenes adultos del
predio de marcos paz llevamos más de 30
años llevando la educación a contextos
de encierro
en las cárceles argentinas la mayoría
son jóvenes en las cárceles argentinas
hay cerca de 70.000 personas y el 90% no
pasa a los 35 años en las cárceles
argentinas el 72% no terminó el colegio
secundario el 60% no lo empezó y más del
30% ni siquiera terminó el colegio
primario
repito no se trata de justificar pero
tenemos que entender para que esta
realidad no nos duela más la cárcel y la
universidad una intersección y rompimos
con nuestra propia metodología en esos
contextos de encierro llevamos a
nuestros docentes tenemos a nuestros
alumnos damos educación en contextos de
encierro y los motines fueron
reemplazados por los habeas corpus pero
claro el sistema penitenciario no está
preparado para responder con las normas
que las leyes del afuera
existen para resolver los conflictos que
se producen en el adentro hacia entonces
estudiar en la cárcel se transformó en
peligroso llevamos como les dije antes
más de 30 años haciendo educación en
contextos de encierro así como 1 de cada
2 personas que se encuentran privadas de
su libertad van a volver a esos mismos
lugares nuestros egresados en contextos
de encierro tienen una tasa de
reincidencia de apenas el 15% este es un
resultado no buscado porque lo que
nosotros hacemos es asegurar un derecho
en contextos de encierro el derecho a la
educación derecho que no se ven privadas
las personas que están en esos lugares
pero este resultado inesperado lleva a
la sorpresa de muchos y hace que entre
otras cosas alguien como yo hoy esté acá
contándole lo que hacemos en estos
lugares desde hace tanto tiempo algunos
algunos puede creer que somos medicina
contra el delito
no no lo somos lo que hacemos es brindar
herramientas para que cada uno para que
cada una pueda elegir con libertad cómo
vivir su vida
la educación es una herramienta que
genera a hombres y mujeres libres y el
trabajo de la universidad de buenos
aires en contextos de encierro muestra y
demuestra la cantidad de conflictos que
se podrían haber evitado si el estado se
hubiese anticipado con esta herramienta
a los lugares en donde esta gente vivía
antes de producir los problemas que los
llevaron a estar en dónde están
la educación construye sociedades
pacíficas la educación brinda
oportunidades a lo mejor de eso se trata
no de que brindemos oportunidades para
que alguna vez y para siempre todas y
todos podamos vivir verdaderamente en
paz muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah